how have you had to like evolve as a
business owner like what are some of the
things that you've really had to be
harsh with yourself on and get better at
and improve on like have you had to like
grow up as a business owner a lot
um which is it's also like it's been a
bit more mature about certain things as
well and I struggle to keep concentrated
on anything so I've got add dyslexic and
everything like that so for me it's like
that's a bit of an ongoing battle I'll
get distracted over anything and as well
it's not letting myself get distracted
with other people and stuff like that
I'd be the easy one to distract in the
office and I should read the last one
that should that should be that person
if someone could you say something on
there like oh yeah what's that and then
yeah so that that's been one thing the
management side of things have been a
bit more having it all sympathy with
people and understanding people that's
obviously it's always a bit of challenge
I might just get on with your word so
what's wrong and learning to understand
people a bit
foreign